[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir la famille bien
ou bien aimé ya quelques têtes que je
reconnais il ya ayez haïdara jésus
karidja aussi l'âge
c'était bien elle était chouette en fait
excuser moi je vais vous faire une
confidence
ça fait plus de deux décennies que à
chaque fois que je me retrouve comme ça
dans une voie là dans une grande réunion
réunion du métier je ne peux pas
m'empêcher c'est plus fort que moi je
peux m'empêcher de compter le nombre de
noirs dans la salle
oui j'en ai oublié un c'est vincent
cassel 5 étoiles rejoint du cinéma
français avant avant la diversité je
devais dans le quota ça doit ou pas
c'est bon allez bon et bon j'ai toujours
pu compter sur les doigts d'une main en
fait le nombre de non blancs alors je
sais qu'on est en france et qu'on n'a
pas vraiment droit de compter un fait
voilà mais là j'ai fait et je crois
qu'on est à peu près 12 et 12 je crois
que c'est un peu le nombre magique 1 ce
soir je pas revenir dessus tout mon
accord
show must go et umons et l'a fait parce
que douze 12 c'est quand même pas mal
ben vous comme on dit leur black watch
chinois à bord est bon appelez-nous
comme vous pouvez nous on a survécu au
white wedding on a survécu aux blacks
fait ce n'est ce pas florence on a
survécu automne de rôle de dealer de
femme de ménage à l'accent bwana on a
survécu au rôle de terroristes on a
survécu à tous les rôles de filles hyper
sexualisée et en fait on voudrait vous
dire on ne doit pas laisser le cinéma
français tranquilles données - vernon
chantera nous des seychelles en fait
voilà on refuse d'être lé mont noir les
bons asiatiques
les lézards alc remercie l'arabe qui
vous laisse tranquille
merci beaucoup partez pas trop loin
voilà on est une famille et on se dit ou
non oui donc alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que l'inclusion
c'est comme ça qu'on dit maintenant
l'inclusion elle va pas se faire sans
vous vous tous je crois qu'on est 1600
donc vous êtes 1588 je vais pas tout
vous comptez j'ai passé les doigts vous
tous qui n'aide pas forcément impactées
par les questions liées à l'invisibilité
ou aux stéréotypes et à la couleur de la
peau voilà la bonne nouvelle c'est que
ça va pas se faire sans vous voilà donc
quand vous allez voir des équipes de
deux tournages les équipes techniques
d'aidé des castings monochrome quand
vous êtes dans les instances de décision
je sais qu'il ya des gens qui prennent
des décisions
ici quand vous êtes dans les lieux où on
décide où vont les financements pensée
inclusion pensée inclusion vraiment ça
passera par vous aussi parce que nous on
n'est pas assez nombreux et on n'a pas
toutes les clefs et surtout ce qui se
joue dans le cinéma ça ne concerne pas
que notre milieu hyper privilégiées ça
concerne l échange enfonce une porte
ouverte toute la société
toute la société n'est ce pas monsieur
sur votre téléphone portable
je sais que vous êtes confirmé aussi je
sais pas je suis hyper optimiste donc
j'ai aucun doute qu'on va y arriver tous
ensemble et que surtout ça va se faire
vite mais vraiment voilà donc mes chers
camarades de l'académie des césar
faisons une maison plutôt qu'une vitrine
une maison qu'ils soient fiers fiers
d'inclure d'inclure toutes les
différences fier pour que les jeunes qui
nous regardent soient eux-mêmes fier de
la recevoir en héritage
mesdames et mesdames les espoirs
bienvenue dans le futur
un futur qu'il vous appartient d'honorer
par votre singularité votre exigence
envers vous même envers les puissants
la route est semée de doute deux moments
de fragilité et de moments de puissance
et c'est tout ça qu'on va aimer voir à
l'écran et c'est tout ça qu'on aimera
vous voir aussi prendre à bras le corps
pour vous élever contre les injustices
et ne pas laisser le cinéma français
tranquilles